die fdp plakatierte ja mit politik mit
neuwagen gebrochen
haben sie nicht angst laut den umfragen
dass er politik mit totalschaden wird
das ist ja macht was sich hier ausleben
durch das mikrofon und gewissen punkt
gutgemacht aussieht sie entscheiden wann
sich nicht entziehen wenn sie selber
sprechen
und doch finden so habe ich das mikro
nicht mal halten
naja bei sie keine reporter sind sondern
die politiker wir können gern die rollen
tauschen wenn ich die rede halten darf
das würde ich gerne sehen dann machen
wir das doch gleich super konnte mich
dann drauf ist sofort sofort das nicht
noch einmal
ich freue mich hier zu sein in
ingolstadt und dann auch noch bei der
fdp
ja das war doch schon der erste gang wie
ist die stimme mir werdet ihr die
anderen parteien platt machen
nein gerufen wir wollen leute überzeugen
das land gestalten aber für uns ist
demokratie nicht darauf ausgerichtet den
politischen wettbewerber zu vernichten
wollen sie die leute überzeugen dass ihr
das land gestalten wollen und die
politik nicht darauf ausgerichtet ist
den wettbewerber zu vernichten
[Applaus]
was erwarten sie sich von der
veranstaltung heute hier guten kaffee in
nette leute fröhliche atmosphäre das
wetter stabil bleibt kein regen und
danach noch ein prozent mehr
ja sehr gut sie haben es wirklich drauf
mit nicht inhaltlich werden ist ja so
als würde das zum programm auch
bundesweit machen nein jetzt reden wir
über betäubungslose ferkelkastration er
werde ich sehr endlich wollen sie
darüber aus hören will hier irgendjemand
über kastration reden ja ich war nachher
noch zur csu soll ich markus söder was
ausrichten
ja mein beileid was wir tun das nicht
hängen könnten sie mir dennoch die
nummer von den grünen-spitzenkandidaten
hier geben damit sich markus söder
vielleicht eine videobotschaft an die
aufnehmen lassen kann
markus söder an der videowirtschaft ja
kann ich machen von hartmann und
schultze oder exakt ich hier über
ich bin in den letzten wochen wenig
dazugekommen nachrichten zu gucken ich
wollte einmal fragen wie läuft denn der
wahlkampf super in bayern läuft es super
in berlin schwieriger
also berlin ist schuld oder mainz also
beides ist denkbar da war ja ein hammer
witz man merkt sie sind zurecht
ministerpräsident meine quoten sind
besser ist die poetische ich war heute
schon richtig im wahlkampf unterwegs ich
war bei herrn h weg zum beispiel und er
hat mir seine telefonnummer gegeben dass
wir ihm vielleicht mal eine
videobotschaft aufzeichnen für die
vielleicht anstehenden
koalitionsverhandlungen sind sie dabei
[Musik]